SPEAKER: I guess unless RJ
does something crazy impulsive
over the next 20
minutes, this will
be our last bald
speaker of the day.
And rounding out the trifecta--
COLT MCANLIS: Rounding out.
That's very punny of you.
Get it?
Rounding, rounding out?
SPEAKER: Oh, it's unintentional.
So yes.
I'm welcoming Colt McAnlis,
who is going to be showing you
some mind-bogglingly awesome
tech around textures, which
I did not think would be as
fascinating is as it was,
but I learned a
lot in the speech
like mostly I'm not very smart.
COLT MCANLIS: You learned
that I get very angry easily.
SPEAKER: Yes.
Colt gets angry at bad
texture compression,
and he might be
getting mad at you
if you don't stay
and watch this talk.
COLT MCANLIS: People
are leaving already
because they realize
this is going to be--
SPEAKER: Alex, I see you.
Don't-- you got to take notes.
All right.
Well, then I'll
guess we'll just--
COLT MCANLIS: You
know what, Alex?
I'm not giving you any
free internet searches.
SPEAKER: That's it.
No free internet for you.
Searches.
COLT MCANLIS: Is that
guy's name really Alex?
SPEAKER: Yeah, he's
on the Games Team.
All right.
Well, before too many other
people get scared away,
let's welcome Colt to the stage.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
COLT MCANLIS: Hello, everybody.
It's getting to the
end of the day, yes?
Who's excited for beer?
You know, that's the most energy
we've got out of this crowd
today.
Caffeine, swag.
nothing.
Beer-- boom!
All right.
I will be short and sweet today.
Hello, I am Colt McAnlis, and
I am a games developer advocate
at Google, which means while
everyone else is off running,
creating the next protein
folder or search engine
or trying to find ways to
cure malaria in the Congo,
I basically sit around and
play "Bejeweled" all day,
which is fantastic.
This is a talk about wrangling
your textures because, well, I
got angry one day.
You see, I found that the more
and more games I downloaded,
the more and more
games did this stuff
to me, which quite
frankly is insulting.
You end up downloading a
game, some free game that
advertises that the download
is about 1.2 megs or 3 megs--
and then all of a
sudden you hit this,
and your phone
turns into a brick
for the next hour and a half
while it downloads something,
right?
Of course, for most of you-- who
has had this experience lately?
Everyone.
Look around in here.
No. keep your hands
up, keep your hands up.
Look around.
If you're developing
a game that does this,
these people are upset with you.
Your intentions are bad,
and you should feel bad.
#Zoidberg.
So the question-- So I didn't
understand this, right?
Most games on the
stores are 2D games.
I should not have to download
50 megabytes worth of content
to find some oscillation
frequency for a bird.
This is wrong.
So I had to ask the question,
what are you people doing?
Right?
I've been in the games
industry for a long time,
and I do understand that
a large bulk of content
does come from textures, but
this is a little bit insane.
So rather than just making
guesses about things,
I proposed a test.
And I actually wrote
a very large framework
to analyze the top
games in Google Play.
So I actually downloaded
a horde of the top free,
top paid, and
top-grossing games.
I ran them through a
large analyzation suite,
which effectively
opened each one of them,
de-compiled the assets, and
then did an analysis on them
to figure out where the
content was actually going.
Because, again, what the
hell are you people doing?
Let's figure this out, right?
This, of course, dumped
out into files and files
and files of data that I
have scraped on your behalf
to present today, and
here's what I found.
No big surprise.
Across the top free, top
paid, and top-grossing games,
over 50% of the content
comes from textures.
Ta-da!
OK, I'm done.
We can go.
Followed up there, number
two is actually code,
but this isn't a
talk about code.
That's going to be next time.
You know what, just
watch my Twitter feed.
You'll see more about
that in the future.
Anyhow, the weird
thing about this
is that top paid had way
more images than free,
and, of course,
gross is some sort
of weird mix between those two.
So we'll get into
that in a second.
If we sort of drill down and
we take a look at the image
section by itself, this is what
really started disturbing me.
Is that if you look at textures
across all of these APKs,
they're PNG files.
Please raise your
hand if you understand
why this is a bad thing.
Yay!
Y'all my people.
This is great.
I'm speaking to a
crowd of my own.
This is all PNG data, which
to me is just mind-blowing
because I don't want to
see a graph like this.
What I hoped to see when
analyzing the top games
in Google Play, was a graph
that looked like this.
That 98% of them were
GPU formatted textures,
and only some small percentage
that you have to use for icons,
or some UI element that's in
JDK code, is actually PNG files.
If your asset allocation
doesn't look like this,
let's have a little
chat, you and I. You see,
non-GPU formatted textures
hurt you in two primary ways.
The first one is load time cost.
When you have your
assets textured
compress in PNG or JPEG or GIF
or any of the other formats,
you have to incur a cost to
load that texture into memory.
And you have to remember, these
devices that we're running on
are not powerhouses
of modern computing.
If anything, they're a nice
focal lens into 10 years ago.
These are low power chips
that run low frequency code,
and you're having them run
through tons of deflate
and JPEG codecs to get your
images into main memory.
That's not going to result
in a very awesome user
experience for your user when
they have to wait to load this.
In fact, how many of you have
profiled how long image-loading
takes in your code?
Did it make you sad?
AUDIENCE: Very.
COLT MCANLIS: The
room has spoken.
The second problem here
is GPU residency costs.
So yes, congratulations,
your artist
has exported a JPEG texture.
Woo-hoo!
That doesn't help you at all
when your game is actually
running.
When the texture
is decompressed,
it's actually uploaded
into memory in full 32 bits
per pixel.
And then it gets to
the GPU, and it's
residing in 32 bits per pixel.
So all of that compression
that you're doing,
your pipelines, your chains,
doesn't help you at all
once the game's into memory.
And quite frankly, that's
the most important part.
For those of you
actually writing
code that runs on a plethora
of devices out there,
you know the difference
in 100 mbs of RAM
can actually exclude you
from entering a region
or marketplace altogether.
We're talking about not
being able to run code
on Google Glass because you
have too many textures, right?
Think about that.
And I understand
the GPU formats are
a little daunting
to a lot of people.
It's this weird sort
of cryptic setup,
and it's GPU specific
a lot of the times.
And this is what people normally
think about when you say,
I want a GPU formatted texture.
They see ETC and ATC
and PVRTC and DXT1,
and their brain starts
going, wait a minute,
I don't know how to
set up my distribution
to make all that work.
Listen, it doesn't
have to start there.
What most people
don't understand
is that there's
actually very usable,
low-bit density
formats on the GPU.
And most of them are
actually 16 bits per pixel.
So we have our basic
32-bit per pixel.
Oh and by the way,
you don't have
to use alpha on everything.
Just so you guys know that.
24 bits per pixels is
actually pretty good.
Following up with that,
we have 4444, right?
So 4 bits per
pixel each channel.
Still 16 bits.
5551.
I would actually
like everyone in your
to do a test across
your assets for me.
In fact, tell you what,
if you guys do this test
and tweet me the
results, I will happily
re-tweet it to everyone else.
Go to your asset
folder for your game
and find out how many
of them would be fine
using binary-only alpha.
Let me know.
Good?
Yes?
I see some really puzzled
faces and some people
leaning over, going,
will PR let us do that?
I don't know.
And then, of
course, we have 565.
Let's look at what these do.
So obviously, we're looking
at a modified bit format.
16-bit formats are
really easy to do.
In fact, get this, you can
actually save your format,
still as PNG, but
you can actually
use a 16-bit header to
load it into memory.
Keep your pipeline the same--
my analysis will still be wrong
because it will still say PNG,
but hey, that's cool, right?
So let's look at the
quality of these.
So matched up here
is 32-bit per pixel.
8 bits a channel.
565, 5551, and 4444.
The only one you can actually
see any visible difference on
is 4444.
And the only place
you can really see it
is in the gradient
behind the parrot.
The reason for this, of
course, is the human eye
picks up very well on
patterns and smooth gradients,
and the quantization going
from 8 bits to 4 bits
actually picks that up.
However, if you will
put up your thumb
and just block out that
gradient part-- Yep.
Everybody thumbs up, thumbs
up, everybody, everybody.
C'mon.
Beer's coming soon.
Just play along.
Block out that
gradient part, and I
want you to look at the
noise inside of that parrot.
You can't tell a difference.
There's so much noise and
so many edges in that parrot
that you can't
actually tell there's
only 4 bits per
channel in that area.
This is what we
should be thinking
of when we're talking
about 16 bits per pixel.
The quality is
actually really good.
And of course, on the
other side of the coin,
here is our GPU specific formats
that scare a lot of people,
right?
DXT, ETC, and PVR.
And of course,
these don't really
look any different
than the 8888,
and that's of course because
they're engineered to do that.
They rely on very
human perceptual models
for visualization.
A lot of very smart people
are paid a lot of smart money
to figure this stuff out.
People who have much more
hair than I do and quite
frankly are a lot
better-looking than I am.
Hopefully they will give
talks like this in the future.
And the so here's
the problem-- here's
what I hear from developers
when I tell them this.
Like, hey, you don't have
to use 32 bits per pixel.
You don't have to use PNG.
They always draw me a diagram
like this and say, hey,
I'm a small indie developer.
Quite frankly, I don't
have the resources
to manage all of the
APKs that this requires.
I don't want to have
to create a APK for ETC
and then one for
PVR because the GPU
chip sets change per device.
And my answer to you
is you don't have to.
You see, if you actually take
the PNG files-- Let's take
just a cropping of
that parrot's head.
That's a 256 by 256
by 3 channel texture.
So just RGB.
The PNG output for that is 192k.
The DXT1, PVR, and ETC are of
course much lower than that.
They're fixed bit,
channel block formats.
No big deal.
If you add them
together, it's only 80k.
I'm going to say that again.
If you add them
together, it's only 80k.
If there's nothing anyone
learns from this or tweets
from this talk, I want it to
be that point right there, OK?
Is that you can actually add
up and distribute all three
GPU-compressed texture
formats for your PNG file
into a single APK and
it's still cheaper
than distributing
the single PNG.
Can I get a round of
applause for that?
[APPLAUSE]
Tweet that.
Tell your friends about.
Shame your artist into that.
Shame your creative
directors into that, right?
There's no reason to
view APKs as having
to be tied to the GPUs.
These are intentionally
GPU-specific formats.
They're meant to be small.
They're meant to be awesome.
Please embrace them.
But if you can't,
and I know sometimes
you won't because
sometimes you don't,
if you have to have the PNGs,
let's be smart about it.
You guys like that, by the way?
I gave that a little bit of
time so everybody can see that.
There's a TM on there.
I read the news.
I'm safe.
Can't say that word.
So if you have to use PNGs,
let's be smart about it, folks.
I want to show you
something that hopefully
will scare every one of you.
I want you all to
be afraid of this.
So here is a 16 pixel.
Or 16 by 16 pixel red image.
Just a red square.
Three channels,
24 bits per pixel.
I just went into Photoshop,
and I just hit File, Save As.
Boom.
That's it, done.
2.74k.
16 by 16.
This is an icon.
File, Save As.
2.74k.
Now, if I do the smart
thing and actually go File,
Save for Web-- everyone
know that button is there?
Please tell me you know
that button is there.
I actually get down to 121
bytes, which quite frankly
is something I would
expect to see, right?
So this should scare you because
how many of you are absolutely
sure that your artists
are hitting Export for Web
on every single one
of your PNG files?
One person, and you have
a hat, so you know what?
I don't trust your opinion.
Gotta let it show.
I'm bald, I own it.
So for those of you
who aren't aware,
PNG is actually a
pretty complex format.
It's actually a
chunked file format,
which means it's
broken up into regions
of data that have a little
bit of header that describes
what information is in it.
And this, quite frankly,
can be anything.
It could be RGB data.
It can actually contain
meta information
about where the
picture was taken.
Like some phones actually
embed the GPS location
of where the picture was
taken in the PNG format.
In addition to that, it's
an alternate pixel format.
So you could have a 1 bit per
channel, 3 channel or 2 bit
per channel, 4 channel or some
weird combination of that.
And finally, all of
that data is actually
thrown into deflate algorithm.
Or I'll use GZIP for
the common term of it.
And all of this is bundled
together as a single PNG file.
Here's why Photoshop actually
had us do 2.7k for that single
image, and that's because photo
editing tools like to hide
stuff in that chunked format.
If you guys actually
open up half the PNGs,
you'll find just
all sorts of stuff.
Just crazy things in there.
I found in one
PNG file there was
a menu to the local
Chinese restaurant.
That may not be true, but
if it is, it's pretty cool.
I'm going to run this
analysis in like a month
and find that block somewhere.
I know one of you
are going to do it.
One of you are
going to do it now.
Like, I wonder if
Colt will find this.
I'll re-tweet that, too.
Now, obviously we at Android
realize this is a problem.
We realize that stuff is
hidden inside of these chunks,
and we try to do the right
thing on your behalf.
The AAP tool, or Android
Asset Packaging tool,
when you actually
do your builds,
will go through in an
attempt to try to strip out
a lot of this information
on your behalf.
And you see it when you
run the Command Line tool.
You'll see packing
all this information,
and it does some fun
stuff over there.
But what is the AAPT
tool actually doing?
Not as much as you
would hope, actually.
This is actually taken
from our documentation.
Effectively what
AAPT will do is it
will create a lossless
optimization to your image.
Only if your image uses
less than 256 unique colors,
will it then convert it
to a palettized image.
Only if there's less
than 256 colors.
And when you think about
all the images in your game,
that might work.
I didn't know how
many times this
was running because this seems
like a pretty important step.
But I wanted to see the
effect of it on our ecosystem.
So I went back to the data.
I re-ran all of my tests where
each one opened up the PNG file
and checked the format.
If this is running a lot,
we would hypothetically
see tons and tons
and tons and tons
of palettized indexed
images, right?
Let's look at it.
This is what I found.
Of a sampling, I'm not going
to say how many files I opened
or what it was.
But of a sampling, here
was the basic counts.
So the first one, of course,
is 32-bit RGB at 30,000 images.
That tells me that 30,000
images were not-- they
had more than 256 unique colors.
It also told me that
there's a lot of alpha
being used in our
games out there.
You can see from the second
row this is the index textures.
These are the ones
that AAPT converted.
Or your artist did
the bright thing
and actually ran
through the entire chain
to convert it out the right way.
OK?
But of course, this
is still only 18,000.
It's almost half.
Only half of this
analysis was actually
categorized the right way.
What scares me
about this analysis
is this column down here--
or this row down here.
24 bits per pixel.
Only 1,000 images were
Listen, I've looked at a lot
of your guys' data assets.
There is a lot more textures
that don't need alpha
that you guys are throwing
in your Texture Packer
output that's getting
bundled with alpha.
And what we're seeing
here is a result of that.
Not accurately separating
out images into their opacity
and non-opacity variance.
And the problem is
that you're then
bloating your assets
because of it.
Anyone guilty of that?
Ah, you didn't raise your hand.
Smart.
One guy.
Props, dude.
I would hit my chest
but there's a mic there.
And of course, a bunch of
other stuff under there.
So basically, we
can see from this
that the AAP tool is doing
a good job of catching
these outliers and
actually turning them
into palettized index
textures, which is great.
But there's still more to do.
You can't just rely on that.
Everybody knows
that if you really
want to compress-- tweet
this, someone tweet this.
Please, somebody tweet this.
I'll wait for you
to get a phone out.
Everybody knows
that if you really
want to compress a PNG file,
you got to do something crazy.
You have to start
with your input image
and apply a Lossy Preprocessor.
Effectively, you have to take
PNG and make it like a JPEG.
You apply a Lossy
Preprocessor, and then you
pass it off to an
algorithm that's
going to produce a
smaller GZIP file.
Believe it or not, GZIP is
actually not the only way
to generate GZIP files,
and, quite frankly,
it actually does a pretty bad
job of generating GZIP files.
There's actually other
algorithms out there.
7-Zip.
Fans of 7-Zip,
round of applause?
[APPLAUSE]
7-Zip will regularly output GZIP
files smaller than GZIP does.
That's pretty cool.
Anyone heard of Zopfli?
Wow.
We got to work on that.
Zopfli is a tool, released from
Google a couple years ago now,
that regularly produces
smaller GZIP files than 7-zip.
AUDIENCE: How do you spell that?
COLT MCANLIS: Z-O-P-H Z- Z-O-F?
You know what?
I found our problem.
Zopfli.
It's like the
Russian bread Zopfli?
Dan will get it.
Great question.
No more questions
from the audience.
I just want to point that out.
I'll be in the back
when that time happens.
Anyhow, you want to apply
a Lossy Precompressor.
What this is going to
do is effectively reduce
the amount of dynamic
range in your image.
It's going to create a
more quantized image that
have similar colors.
This, of course, is going
to be eaten and take apart
by a better deflate algorithm
giving you a big explosion--
a better small, compressed file.
The best part of
this is that you
don't have to write any
of this code by yourself.
If you just do a
simple Google-- here,
let me Google that for you.
You will get a plethora, an
overflow, a flood of tools
out there that already
do all of this for you.
Round of applause
if you're already
using one of these
tools in your pipeline.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
I'm going to come
back next year.
I'm going to give the same talk.
I expect the whole audience to
be clapping when we do that.
Can we agree to that?
Round of applause?
[APPLAUSE]
And there will still
be no more questions
at the live stream
on that talk, either.
So the cool thing is
just go out, just pick
any one of these,
any one of these
and add it to your
pipeline, and you're
going to get better compression
than already what you're doing.
The analysis I'm seeing already
shows that a lot of people
aren't using this.
Because these tools are
going to accurately analyze
your content.
It's going to figure out how
many channels you really need.
It's going to apply
Lossy Preprocessors.
Better compressors.
In fact, you'll
see the ZopfliPNG.
Where did it go?
There it goes.
That's how you spell Zopfli.
You know, let me
file a bug on that.
So that's ZopfliPNG.
That's actually
going to apply Zopfli
to the deflate section
of your PNG compression.
Of course, if that's too crazy
because each one of those
has little variants
and whatnot, I highly
recommend just starting with
a tool called ScriptPNG.
What ScriptPNG will do is
it will provide a directory
for you that you can download
all of those other PNG
compressors.
And what it will do
is given an image,
it will find the one that
produces the best output.
So it will actually run your
image through all 50 of those
if you want to, to produce
and find the best compression,
and that's the PNG file
that will get shipped out.
You don't even got
to do the hard work.
You just got to set it up, and
the artist hits the button,
and it goes off its way.
Round of applause
for lazy artists.
[APPLAUSE]
See, I know when I'm
talking to my people
when they applaud at
lazy artists, right?
This is the programmers
in the house.
So this is--
everything I've talked
about before this was OK.
This is where I'm going
to get really nerdy.
Just letting you guys know.
So let's say you do all this.
I'm going to let you
know you're going
to hit a point of
diminishing return.
It doesn't matter how
much compressing you add
or how much Lossy Preproccessing
or what format you do to it,
you're going to hit a point
of diminishing return.
That if you're only
thinking in terms of images,
you're never going
to break that point.
You have to think about
the data that you're
using, how you're using
it, to get better results.
So I did some tests.
This is a sprite sheet
I grabbed off the web.
This is from Glitch.
It was a game, it was
a big MMO game online,
and they actually went under and
open-sourced all their assets.
So thank you to
the Glitch people
for open-sourcing your content
so I can use it in my talk.
Round of applause for that.
[APPLAUSE]
Beer got more applause,
unfortunately.
So anyhow, we see in our games
lots of spreadsheets like this.
The artists have hand
drawn some animation,
and they export it out in this
large matrix of information.
And we see this over and
over and over again, right?
You've got a talking
tiki head, or you
have someone getting hit
in the face with a pie.
They just render
out this content,
and sometimes,
each of the frames
actually differ by
a very small margin
between the previous frames.
And when you look at a sprite
sheet like this, you go,
well, It's good that they've at
least packed it into an Atlas
so we know they're not
wasting too many sprites,
but there's still
a lot of data here
that we're not able to
compress even with GPU formats.
And the problem is there's
lots of duplicate wasted pixels
that sort of act as the border
or the transparent area.
In addition to
this, there's lots
of duplicate pixels
between frames.
This image moves very
little between two frames.
The question you should
really be asking yourself
is well, wait a minute, this
is effectively just a flipbook
animation.
Aren't there already compression
formats out there that do that?
And you're right.
There's GIF.
Or "jif."
I'm not getting into that war.
There's H264, and of
course, there's WEBM.
These are codecs that are
built to of course compress
animated content, and they
do one helluva job at it.
Except for GIF.
You just don't.
Just don't.
WEBM, that's pretty good.
The problem with
these, though, is
you can't really
use them in game.
So first off, once
again, we're talking
about lower-rent hardware
here, and unless you're
using the H264 hardware
decoder for everything,
you're going to hit a
pretty hard burden decoding
each one of your frames.
Because every single frame of
your animation has to be CPU
decoded to a Raw 32-bit
texture in the CPU
and then uploaded
back to the GPU.
So again, these only
help you in distribution.
They don't help you
at all on the GPU
where the problem really exists.
Where the stability
is really a problem.
What you really want is a
format that looks like this.
You have some
hyper-compressed format,
and you can load it
right into the CPU
and maybe do some
compression there.
But really you want
it to go to the GPU
in a super-compressed
form that has
some information about
these sprite sheets
in its hyper-compact,
decompressable form.
So you can actually decompress
it in the pixel shader
as you're rasterizing
your quads.
So there's no interim step here.
There's no middle step.
Everything happens
in the pixel shader.
There wasn't one out there,
so I built one of these.
It's called Crabby.
it's on my GitHub page.
You can see the
URL at the bottom.
It's going to be at
the end of every slide.
Effectively what Crabby is is
a compressed texture format
for GPU reconstruction.
It's effectively
built to minimize
the amount of duplicate
pixels in a sprite sheet,
and the results are
actually pretty cool,
if I do say so myself.
So how it works.
We effectively taken an
input image like this,
and we actually store
unique 4 by 4 pixel blocks
so any duplicate blocks
get completely removed.
We only create a pixel
block palette from this.
In addition to that,
each one of the frames
actually creates a
frame texture that's
a quarter resolution that
provides an index to what
pixel block that's
actually going to use.
So pretty simple.
We're effectively doing
palettized indexing,
but we're using it
on blocks of pixels
instead of single pixels.
Pretty straightforward.
I'm not a genius here, guys.
I'm bald.
Look at me.
I don't do great things.
I just read books.
And the results are
actually pretty good.
So take this input image.
So the source 32-bit per
pixel image in distribution.
So this is the PNG
version of this file
that has then been GZIPed.
So there's two compression
algorithms going on there.
207k.
However, when it's decompressed
into CPU memory-- so the minute
you decompress that, 2.48
megs uploaded to your GPU.
2.4 megs.
OK?
When you run this
through Crabby,
you get 129k distribution,
364k in the GPU.
[CLAPPING]
Thank you.
Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
That guy.
I'm going to swag you.
All the swag I have.
Do we have swag left?
Still, you're awesome.
Let's dig deeper.
The way I actually output
texture information from Crabby
allows you to add further
compression to it.
So that raw-- let me show you
that raw palette texture again.
See that raw palette texture?
That's just output
as a TGA file.
You can actually
then compress it
with DXT or PVR or JPEG or
GIF or whatever you want to.
And the result for that
gets you even smaller.
So if we took just the raw
32 bit per pixel image,
and we just ran it
through DXT1 just raw,
we end up with about
319 in CPU memory.
However, if we combine DXT
compression plus the Crabby
output, we hit 84k.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
What I really hope
comes out of Crabby--
right now it's sort of
a research project--
I want all of you to go test it.
Break it.
Please, dear god,
break the code.
What I really hope
comes out of this
is we start looking
at different ways
to attack our texture problem.
It's not just about
block formats.
We can actually recompose
all the stuff in the GPU,
and quite frankly, the
tests I have show it's
still running very performantly
on all sorts of devices.
And actually, if you guys
would like to run tests,
I'd love to hear your feedback
on where it's falling.
But 2.48 megs to 84k,
that's a huge savings.
That's the difference in
running on every device
and only devices
in North America.
If you listened to Bob
Meese's talk earlier,
it's the difference in a
lot of potential users.
And the fact is that
distribution and size
of your assets do correlate
to conversions and downloads.
So with my analysis, these
were the numbers I found.
On average, the top free
game was around 34 megs.
Now, for those of you who
know, the size of APK limits
is around 50 megs
right now, and then you
can use the OBB files if
want to get larger than that.
And you see the OBBs
down in top paid.
On average, the top
paid game is 125 megs.
Average.
If you just look at this graph,
there's some pretty numbers
here.
But what you should
really take away
from this is that there is
in fact a correlation of size
of the assets the user has to
load and the ability for it
to be successful
at a price point.
Users who are expecting free
content want to click a button
and play now.
They don't want to wait 20
minutes for a loading screen.
And because of that, the
content's got to be small.
It's got to be tightly
packed, and dear god, it
has got to be awesome.
Crabby allows you to hit that.
Using GPU textures
allows you to hit that.
Doing better GPU compression
If you only tweet three
things from this talk today,
tweet these three things.
Number one.
Replace your PNGs
with GPU textures.
Do it.
Distribute all three
of them in your APK.
It's still going to
be smaller than a PNG.
Your users will thank you.
Number two.
Use advanced PNG compression
for those that you cannot turn
into GPU textures.
Just go pick any from that
matrix or use ScriptPNG.
Trust me.
It's going to be awesome.
And when in doubt, look
for unique and awesome ways
to compress your
texture data further.
Please, for the love of all that
is holy, go to my GitHub page,
grab Crabby.
Check it out.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
This is how you
get a hold of me.
I want to hear from you, and
I'm going to be in the back
after all of this.
Come find me.
Let's talk.
Thank you.